today africa is unfortunately known as
the poorest continent in the world
by far from the worthless trillion
dollar bills found in zimbabwe
to the 85 percent of africans who live
on less than 5.50
per day it's no question that africans
have had it tough
however there are a lucky few africans
who have been able to accumulate
extraordinary amounts of wealth one of
these lucky africans
is aliko dangote who is currently worth
11.9 billion dollars
so here's how aliko dangote became
africa's richest person
taking a look back we have to go quite a
bit back in time
as illegal's wealth literally stretches
back centuries starting with his great
grandfather
al-hassan dan tata al-hasan was born in
1877 in the nigerian town of babaji
though he had several siblings life
wasn't too bad as his parents were
prosperous traders and caravan leaders
his father madhu abdullahi was also the
son of a successful merchant named baba
talatan
and baba talatan was also the son of a
successful merchant
so we have a long lineage of successful
merchants but
everything would turn upside down early
on in all hawsen's life
and all hassan was 80 years old his
father abdullahi would pass away
and his mother would leave behind the
children and move to ghana
as a result all hassan would find
himself living with an old slave woman
named tata
tata raised alhassan and his siblings
and she basically became their mother
in fact alhassan's last name don tata is
derived from the name of this woman
in the hasa language dantata means son
of tata
dotata was a loving woman and took care
of the children as if they were her own
as you would guess she didn't have any
money so
the kids had to earn their own money to
support themselves some of them begged
for foods and clothes
while others chose to work for low wages
al haasen was one of the few
that chose to work but just as he
started to consistently make enough
money to support himself as a teenager
the kano civil war rolled around all
hawsen and his siblings would be
captured and sold a slave during the
civil war
fortunately the war didn't last too long
and all hassan would be able to purchase
his freedom
after tension settled down with
basically no money left once again
though
al-hasan would travel to ghana hoping
that his biological mother could help
him
to his disappointment though his mother
would take al-hasan to a malam
who is basically a teacher and she told
him that he can stay with the malam
until he was ready to return to bebe
realizing that he was truly on his own
alhassan would do anything
and everything possible to earn a bit of
money on thursdays and fridays
he worked for money and during the rest
of the week he begged for food
most of his earnings though went to his
malleum in an effort to break out of
stagnation
al-hasan would eventually move back to
babaji and decide to follow in the
footsteps of his father
starting in 1906 at the age of 29 while
hawsen began trading various european
goods
including beads necklaces and various
cloths
all hassan conducted most of his trades
in the city of kano
but he decided to continue living in
babaji at first
eventually though al-hawson would
relocate to kano
after six years of trading all hassan
would finally break out of poverty and
move up to the middle class
in 1912 europeans became interested in
ground nuts
and they contacted a bunch of well-known
merchants in kono to provide them with
ground nuts
at the time all hassan wasn't nearly
notable enough to be contacted by the
europeans
but he quickly realized a great
opportunity of exporting ground nuts
you see many merchants in africa had
become extremely wealthy selling cocoa
beans to the europeans
and alhassan believed that he could
succeed in a similar manner using ground
nuts
but first he had to get noticed by a
major european exporter
now that all hassan had his basic needs
taken care of though
this was much easier between 1912 and
al-hasan would vigorously build up his
reputation in kono
and he would save up every penny he made
apparently
he was extremely frugal he also worked
on his english skills to make it easier
to trade with europeans
and just as he hoped in 1918 the royal
niger company owned by the british
reached out to all hassan in hopes of
trading ground nuts
all hassan would instantly accept the
offer and he would quickly get to work
on establishing his dominance in the
trade
though al haasen was unwilling to spend
any money on himself
he didn't think twice when it came to
investing into his relationship with the
niger company
while all of his fellow merchants used
pack animals to transport the goods
al haasen used the money he saved up
over the past 12 years
to ship his ground nuts on steamships
this earned him a lot of respect from
the europeans
and over the next few years many of them
formed partnerships with
all hassan these european connections
allowed all hawsen to quickly scale up
his other trading goods as well
including coal nuts grains pressure
stones and many more
as this trading grew all austin started
to hire employees
and some of them even lived with him
soon enough
alhassan jumped from being another
successful merchant to being the richest
businessman in kono by 1922
at this point the hardest part of his
journey was behind him
he had broken out of poverty established
a name for himself
and now he was the richest person in
kano all he had to do was maintain
and grow his business and this is
exactly what all hawsen did for the rest
of his life
in 1940 al-hasan would actually attempt
to open his own exporting company
this way he did not have to rely on the
royal niger company which was now known
as the united africa company
however his application to become an
exporter would be declined
and all hawsen would be forced to
continue working as a middleman for
european companies
this wasn't a bad gig by any means
though so al-hasan just focused on
growing what he had
by the time he died in 1955 he grew to
be the richest man
in all of west africa it's crazy to
think that he started off begging for
food
anyway moving forward we have all
hassan's children and grandchildren
all hassan had raised his kids and
grandchildren with a great appreciation
for wealth
hard work and success so they didn't
just go out and burn all of all hawsen's
wealth
in fact they actually did a great job in
maintaining their business and expanding
into more sectors
including rice and oats with that being
said though
none of them were that ambitious and
they didn't do much to take the business
to the next level
that is until aliko dangote aliko
dangote was born in kano on april 10th
given that all hassan had passed away
two years before that all hassan's son
or alico's grandfather sanusi dantata
was running the business
aliko's father actually passed away
early on so
alika would primarily be raised by his
grandfather sanusi
this gave aliko a unique view into the
daily operations of the business
and made him really interested in
growing his own business aliko would
attend allah also university
which is widely known as being the most
prestigious university in the islamic
world
aliko earned a bachelor's in business in
and he would return to nigeria with the
business idea ready to go
his plan was to follow his grandfather's
footsteps and expand to soft commodities
instead of selling the commodities to
european though aliko wanted to import
commodities into africa
and sell them to local consumers his
first two targets were rice from
thailand and sugar from brazil
and to get his business started up he
borrowed some money from his family
some reports suggest that he borrowed
the money from his uncle while others
suggest that the money was from his
grandfather
but either way he got a 2 500 loan from
one of his family members and he
promised to pay them back within three
years
now that's no small loan of a million
dollars but adjusting for inflation
it's equivalent to eleven thousand two
hundred dollars today so
not a small amount per se given this
family's reputation
it wasn't too difficult for alico to
secure some international suppliers and
start selling rice and sugar locally
according to aliko the business was a
cash cow and he profited as much as ten
thousand dollars per day
that's the same as forty four thousand
eight hundred dollars today
aliko paid back his family member within
three months and he was off to the races
over the next two decades alika expanded
from just selling rice and sugar
to also selling pasta salt and flour by
expanding his reach in africa
and his line of products alika grew his
personal fortune to hundreds of millions
of dollars
but he wouldn't reach the elusive
billion dollar mark till he embarked on
his great-grandfather's final vision
up until 1997 aliko was simply a middle
man
funneling commodities into africa but in
liko decided to venture into production
and stop being the middle man
he already had a large customer base and
plenty of money too
so the transition wasn't too difficult
and aliko would quickly grow to be one
of the only billionaires in nigeria
at this point the nigerian government
would actually trust him enough to award
him
a cement factory to this day we don't
really know the details behind why they
awarded him the factory
maybe the factory was failing and they
wanted him to stage a recovery
or maybe it was a thank you gift for
driving down sugar prices
i'm not sure but whatever the reason
aliko was awarded as a mentor factory
and he would leverage the factory to
expand it into cement production
as well according to aliko the key to
his success has been his tendency to
reinvest the majority of his profits
back into the business apparently most
african businessmen like to keep most of
their money in cash for some reason
all of this reinvesting seems to have
worked out for elico as all of his
businesses boast extremely impressive
stats today
the don't go to sugar refinery for
instance is the third largest in the
world
producing a whopping eight hundred
thousand tons of sugar annually
considering this it's not surprising
that aliko dangote has been africa's
richest person since 2012.
since reaching the pinnacle of success
in the business world aliko has shifted
to focusing on advancing nigeria
as a whole in 2009 for instance aliko
focused on providing fast internet
service to nigerians
by installing 14 000 kilometers of fiber
optic
his latest project is to produce and
potentially even eliminate nigeria's
dependence on oil imports
currently nigeria imports 7 billion
worth of fuel
every year despite the fact that nigeria
is the biggest oil producer
in africa aliko is investing 15 billion
dollars which is more than his net worth
into building one of the world's biggest
oil refineries in nigeria
hopefully the oil refinery does come to
fruition and help nigeria become more
oil independent
but that's what aliko dangote is working
on today and how he became the richest
person
in africa what do you guys think about
the story of aliko and especially his
great grandfather al haasen
comment that down below also drop a like
if you would like to see africa catch up
to the western world
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one